meantime let's talk about this democrats
rolling out a plan that would allow them
to pack
the supreme court with liberal justices
republicans stole two seats on the
supreme court
and now it is up to us to repair that
damage we must expand the court and we
must abolish the filibuster to do it
i wish we didn't have a far right
supreme court majority that is hostile
to democracy
itself but here we are some people will
say we're packing the court we're not
packing it we're unpacking it
republicans are lining up to blast the
idea
they're introducing a bill to add four
new seats to the supreme
court so the democrats can pack the
court
destroy its legitimacy and guarantee the
rulings
that liberals want it will be the end of
the supreme court's legitimacy and the
end of the rule of law in america
i think it's a terrible idea you make
the supreme court basically a political
football
hmm darn it dana i uh wanted to i had a
little uh
joke to introduce you with but uh we're
not gonna do it because we're just gonna
get right in it so i get to save
time you'll save next time yeah
something about deep sea diving into a
test tube
all right so with dagen jesse dana and
the great harold ford jr
uh harold you're a unicorn meaning
you're a modern democrat
that doesn't make the world scream so if
this
if the party continues down this far
left path how long before you're no
longer welcome in it
well there's a lot there let me try to
unpack it since there's a lot of talk
about packing today
i think i think two things first this is
a bad idea
it was bad when president roosevelt
attempted to do it
it's bad now but we should understand
where it comes from
and i hope that a compromise might
emerge from this first off i think the
country will learn a lot about how our
court system is organized as the
president's commission
analyzes this there may be some
quarreling about the people on the
commission are they too liberal are they
too moderate are they not moderate
enough
but i think we'll have an education
experience understanding how our circuit
courts organize how the supreme court
one time was a smaller number it's now
the number it is now
and and basically educate the nation
around that what i hope comes out of it
jesse is that we we can maybe go back to
the rule that both
my friend senator graham and uh leader
mcconnell laid out a few years ago
we should not confirm justices in an
election year
if that rule had been adhered to i think
you would find it really really
difficult
for some democrats to even consider
doing what some of them laid out today
but let me be clear i'm opposed to it
but i understand where it's coming from
and there's a way to fix it we should
set out a rule about who can be
confirmed in what period of time they
can be confirmed then we should stick to
it
all right let's go to greg up in the
corner there
you are i look at all of these moves uh
whether it's the dc statehood
or the supreme court packing it's not to
enhance
democracy but to expand and preserve
power
isn't that obvious it's so obvious and
watch my show god filled exclamation
point tonight at 11 o'clock
we're gonna have some great guests i
don't know who should be more insulted
uh
me or you and uh harold fortunately
confuses us with each other
are you saying we all i heard what you
said yesterday jesse
i heard what you said yesterday we're
gonna have to upgrade your studio then
harold
all right um yeah great i love the line
we're not we're not trying to pack the
court we're trying to unpack it they
just
should say we're not raising taxes we're
cutting taxes
and the media will probably parrot it
listen pelosi's not even putting this on
the floor
biden's not going for it so this is dead
but it shows you
how tyrannical the instincts are of the
far left
not content with having full control
over hollywood
academia big tech big media the house
the senate the white house they're
targeting the supreme court
because if they can pack the supreme
court
they can just nuke socialism through and
nuke pelosi's
election law power grabbed through and
you'll never have another republican in
the white house again and exactly as you
said
this is what this is the democratic
party is basically a monopoly that needs
to be
busted up and right now you have a
situation where
the far left is so bloodthirsty
that they can't even stand a little bit
of power because that power that
conservative majority
interprets the constitution strictly
they believe the
constitution is an obstacle to socialism
so they want a jurist in there that is
going to reimagine
race and gender and precedent and
individual rights
and create whatever fantasy he or she
wants from there
it is ironic though the same people that
are pushing this were the ones
howling about trump trashing
institutions now within the first
100 days of taking power they want to
abolish the police the filibuster and
pack the court
this couldn't be done by a let's say
less impressive group of people hank
johnson
uh ed markey jerry nadler as donald
trump would say
they're not sending their best so this
isn't going to happen but republicans
will get a lot of traction on this
they're going to just bleed these
democrats dry in the midterms running
ads
because no one agrees with it at all you
know
dana you know what gets my goat besides
my brand new goat
trap all the people
who pretend to be about honesty and
transparency and they hated trump
and they appreciated joe yet it was
trump who told
everybody exactly what he was going to
do and then he tried to do it
whereas joe told everybody what he was
going to do
and is now doing the opposite he was
supposed to be
a centrist he was supposed to unify
everybody if he's a centrist i'm amish
it's he's gone so completely far left i
don't even know if he knows where he is
at this point
and if you're amish i'm just i can't
think of anything
um a satanist okay yeah i mean if it
fits it
fits i i think about karl rove's column
this morning the wall street journal in
which he said
it could turn out that joe biden ends up
being the most partisan president ever
i don't think that's what he necessarily
intended but that's where the party is
going
but you saw how quickly today nancy
pelosi was like yeah not happening why
because she can count votes she knows
she only has a very narrow majority i
think only two seats now
and the judicial crisis network is going
to spend a million dollars regardless
talking about this crackpot idea and
making sure everybody in america
knows everything about it i am a little
surprised that jerry nadler decided to
jump on board this because
to me that adds a patina of legitimacy
to this whereas
before pelosi could have just said like
she does with the squad like yeah
please go and do something else you're
bothering me i got things to do over
here
um the fact that the republicans are now
going to be able to press
every single democrat and say do you
support this do you support this
and they're all going to have to be on
record saying it it's a completely
unforced error
and i think joe biden doing the
commission was sort of like
basically trying to placate but now he's
going to
i think he should take a much stronger
stance and just say i'm not doing it
um degan as you heard uh uh
dana mentioned the patina the patina of
what
was it legitimacy legitimacy which
sounds like the name of a of a mystery
novel the patina
uh i don't know what i'm talking about
at this point dean uh save me
tell me what you think of this court
packing well uh patina is my safe word
so that's a little weird
um i think that
i think that this legislation
is a way to intimidate the court what we
heard today
uh from congress and this bipartisan
commission
is a way to intimidate the court from
the executive branch right out of the
white house and what i mean
is that it's a way to threaten the um
justices on the court on say rulings uh
judicial review of left-wing policies
and the cases they take up
because this all started in 2019. this
is before amy coney barrett
at her confirmation this has nothing to
do with that
this was led by sheldon whitehouse in
the senate along with maisie hirono
richard blumenthal kirsten gillibrand
and now head of the judiciary committee
dick dermott they sent a amicus brief to
the court
threatening the justices saying if you
take up this gun rights case out of new
york
we will restructure the court so this
group this handful of senators
threatened the court with packing and
it was so bad in fact that um
samulino called him out on it so that's
what they're trying to do there and
it actually worked because the chief
justice joined the liberals and backed
away from ruling
on that new york gun case so this is
what they're up to they're trying to
basically intimidate the justices about
what cases they take
up to not make uh rulings that would
help conservatives if you will but this
uh party i call them these democrats the
party of veruc assault
spoiled brats i want it and i want it
now
amicus is my safe word
terrible all right coming up
you don't even know what a safe word is
dana